SCOTT SOSEBEE: Hey, everyone.
My name is Scott Sosebee.
I can't thank Google
enough for having
me here today to moderate this
conversation with our guest.
If you've been living under a
rock, and don't know who he is,
he is one of the most
successful and well known
businessmen in the world.
New York Times best
selling author,
Grammy winning recording artist,
co-founder of the hottest rock
band in the world, KISS, ladies
and gentlemen, Gene Simmons.
Thank you, sir.
GENE SIMMONS: No microphones?
You guys can hear us?
All right.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: So you have
written a book, Me, Inc.
GENE SIMMONS: Yeah.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: A lot of
these people probably
have not read it.
I have.
You explain how to
become successful.
GENE SIMMONS: No,
that's not fair.
It really isn't fair, and
I'll tell you what I mean.
When I came to this
country-- English
is not my original language.
This is my third language.
I spoke Hebrew, then Hungarian,
and then your language.
And we'll get to why that's
important in a second.
Then I learned to speak German,
then a little bit of Japanese.
Anybody speak Japanese?
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
How's my accent?
Oh, nobody speaks Japanese.
OK, forget it.
I thought somebody said, I do.
But in all seriousness,
when I came to America,
and I went through the
educational system,
and I learned, in other words,
my inferred fiduciary duty,
I had to learn how to speak
the language of the culture,
dress British, think Yiddish--
see the pregnant pause so they
can, dress British-- And
so those are the keys.
That's the first step.
Learn language skills, then
people skills, ad infinitum ad
nauseum.
But school didn't teach
me anything, you know?
I learned about Columbus, and
the original first nations
here, who weren't from India,
but they're called Indians.
And then all of a sudden, you
have to start earning a living.
And nobody prepares you
for how life actually is.
I mean, I want to turn it over
to you for one quick second.
Since you're all in very
dramatic silhouettes,
I can't tell who's
the best looking one,
so I'm going to ask you, may I?
What do you do at Google?
Or if you do work at Google?
AUDIENCE: Oh yes, I do.
I'm a partner manager.
GENE SIMMONS: You're
a partner manager.
I don't know what
that title does.
What does a partner manager do?
AUDIENCE: Make
sure our partners,
like, support and
sell Google apps.
GENE SIMMONS: I see.
So Zuckerberg must pay you
a fortune for doing this,
and has now made you a partner
in the entire entity, right?
I'm sure that's true.
So what was the name
of the high school
class, in all
seriousness, what was
the name of the
class in high school
that prepared you for making
the money that you're making now
in the job you're doing?
AUDIENCE: High school
class, hmmmmm...
GENE SIMMONS: Probably not.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GENE SIMMONS: Yeah.
Probably nothing.
Because they don't teach
life in high school.
The educational
system, and by the way,
I was a sixth
grade teacher once.
I was.
Why is that funny?
[CLAPPING FOR ATTENTION]
Attention, class!
Come on, why was that funny?
I'm serious.
I was a sixth grade
teacher in Spanish Harlem.
Yes, I was.
That's uptown.
And on the first day, I
heard, [SPEAKING SPANISH],
which does not mean, good
morning, Jewish person.
Anybody speak Spanish?
How was the accent?
[INAUDIBLE] It's a
little [INAUDIBLE],
with a little Mexicano.
Right?
But in all seriousness,
what we learn in school,
doesn't prepare many people
for much of anything.
You learn, sort of,
facts and figures.
It's kind of like
playing Trivial Pursuit.
You know the answers.
Great, now how do I make money?
You don't.
And so I use this term
often, many times,
the inferred fiduciary
duty to yourselves.
It's your responsibility
to learn whatever
it is you need to unlock
that key that opens the door.
Because the mountain ain't
coming to you, Mohammed.
Kim, who is very beautiful and
who was walking around here
someplace, and was our
escort, taught herself
how to do that
push-button stuff,
that the rest of the world--
because don't presume
that everybody's on
computers and does
all that kind of stuff.
She taught herself how to
do that, which then led her
to this, and on and on.
So I wanted to,
finally, even though you
can tell I love the
sound of my own voice,
finally, I wanted
to write a book that
helps the great unwashed masses.
And I mean that with
all due respect.
There are many, many,
many times more people
that are not like you, that
don't have credit cards,
don't understand what social
media is, don't understand
how the free market
capitalist system works,
don't understand
how to get a job.
They really don't.
They're the ones who built
this building that you're in,
that you bought for
$2 or $3 billion.
So they know how
to do one thing.
They probably goofed
around school.
They didn't learn the stuff
they need, so they wound up
being menial laborers, and
still don't understand concept--
So I wanted to write a
book in plain English,
without graphs, without
using words like meta.
Right, Kim?
On the way in she said meta, and
then I asked her what it meant,
and she couldn't do it.
Well give me an
application, and I
don't mean a
computer application.
See that, that's a different
kind of application.
So "Me, Inc."
Is a kind of a
Cliff Notes of life.
It's not very specific.
It just points the
finger back at you.
So there's a chapter called
lady entrepreneurship,
and kid entrepreneurs,
and there's actually
a chapter called
"Speak English."
It gets people really angry.
What are you trying
to tell me I can't
speak Serbian and Zimbabwean?
No, you go right ahead.
Speak any language you want to.
Remember, I don't have
a horse in this race.
I wasn't born in America.
I just recognize that
I have an advantage
if I know the
language of business.
And in this culture,
in this time,
as a matter of fact
anywhere on planet Earth,
English is a decided advantage
in the language of business.
Just like you have a decided.
Advantage, because you know
how to do all that social media
stuff, and Google stuff that
I can barely understand.
You're better at this than I,
because you know that stuff.
So I can continue on, but
any oxygen left for you?
SCOTT SOSEBEE: Sure.
GENE SIMMONS: OK, go ahead.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: So this book
is really easy to understand.
GENE SIMMONS: Very simple.
Because if I have a self
imposed mandate in this book--
because I don't
have enough money,
but I have a lot of money.
I love saying that.
I do.
I have shitloads of money.
I sleep on fucking money.
I shit money.
Trying to think of other--
But in all seriousness,
nobody helped me.
I really want the book,
and I know it's going to,
because it already has-- I
wanted to inspire and motivate
somebody to get themselves
off the fucking floor
and do something with your
life instead of going,
I'm 24 years old, I'm
going to go on a vacation.
What?
You're going to
go on a vacation?
To do what?
You're just waiting to die.
The days are going by.
The fuse has been lit, and
after a while, we're done.
So it seems to me, we have
a limited amount of time.
Here, let me give
you a wake-up call.
This is what I realized.
One third of your life
is spent comatose.
You're asleep.
You're not even alive.
That leaves 2/3.
I'm going to live
to be 80 years old.
Great, take a third off.
You're asleep.
You're dead.
Now you've got 2/3 of your life.
OK.
So you work seven days a week,
and you take two days off.
Two days off, every
week, times 52 weeks
is 104 days doing nothing.
You're watching Oprah reruns,
or whatever you're doing.
I'm sorry, you don't
watch TV anymore.
Now it's on this.
Should have known that.
And then you've got
Christmas vacation,
I forgot to tie my
shoelaces vacation,
pregnancy leave,
and even, you women
have to do that-- see that was
a slight attempt at a joke.
And then Hanukkah, of
course, and all the holidays.
By the time you're done, at
the end of the year, 365 days,
you work a minuscule
amount of days.
The rest of the time is yours.
So the real question is, what
are you going to do with that?
As far as I'm concerned,
it's a huge opportunity.
Especially for young
people to understand
that all that time
can be used for me.
To create a me business
model, me incorporated.
And there's some rules
that greatly increase
your chances of
making a lot of money.
Same things I did, by the way.
Never put your eggs, all
your eggs in one basket.
I didn't come up with that.
But that's what
Wall Street does.
It's called spreading the risk.
Never bet all your
money on black.
39 black, all my money.
Win or lose.
Yeah, the problem is when
you lose, you lose your ass.
You lose everything.
So, by the way, am I allowed
to say words like ass and shit?
OK.
Great.
Fucking great.
And so it's a very serious
book that's a little gimmicky,
and is really designed
to help, perhaps not
you, but the masses in
understanding that every day,
they should pick up, or
go online, the Wall Street
Journal.
Don't read the whole thing.
Just go to the left hand
margin, and read those little--
there are two margins.
One is business.
One is politics and news.
You'll understand something.
Because they won't watch on TV.
CNN now does cooking travelogue
shows and forensic science.
I'm not making that up.
You can't find a hard
news item anywhere.
Fox blasts and destroys all
the other cable news agencies.
Good, bad, or otherwise.
Whether you agree
with them or not,
it's 24 hours of that stuff.
Although it may not be
to your political liking.
But they're getting 4 to
6 million people on that.
The nightly news,
CBS and NBC, is
getting 300,000
or 400,000 views.
Bill O'Reilly can
get $6 million.
The point is nobody's reading
newspapers, nobody's following
news, nobody's finding
out how to do stuff.
Because it's so easy to
watch women who text and fall
over fountains in malls, dogs
that walk backwards and wear
yarmulkes.
You know, it's like all
that stuff is so much more
interesting.
And business is boring, and I
want to make it interesting.
Which is why I wear leather
pants, and in the band I'm in,
I wear more makeup and higher
heels than your mommy ever did.
I want to make it interesting.
I want to make
business interesting,
because it'll help
a lot of people.
And there was an economist that
actually had a singularity,
this thought that if these
United States of America,
and therefore the
world, because we're
the biggest wasters, the
biggest spenders of everything,
if we did certain very
smart moves, which
is to balance the budget
and all that stuff,
everybody could be
hypothetically rich.
The definition of rich is
anything above $250,000,
says the United
States government.
Which actually
it's the IRS, which
is not a part of the government.
You can't sue the IRS,
designed that way.
But the definition of
rich starts at $250,000.
That's when you're at
the highest tax rate.
And economists are telling us
that if we do certain things,
there's more than enough
money for everybody
to have their own house,
yup, without exception.
With their own property, their
own estate, and all that stuff.
But we're not doing
it the right way.
Because it's easier to walk
by the dessert tray, which
is what I did, and keep
eating those carbs.
Because they taste good,
and because they're easy.
The thing that's good for
you, who dreams of spinach?
I don't.
I have no idea what that meant.
Your turn.
I'll shut up.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: So
your book could easily
inspire a single individual
to go out and build an empire.
It's really inspirational.
GENE SIMMONS: Me, I did it.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: Did
you have a book,
similar that inspired you?
GENE SIMMONS: No.
No, my biggest
inspiration, actually,
was a combination of my
mother, who still to this day
doesn't speak English very well.
She, at 14 years of
age, was a survivor
of Nazi Germany's
concentration camps.
Came to Israel six
months after the country
became an independent state.
And I was born six months
after the country was born.
It was nothing.
There was dirt.
I never saw a toothbrush,
never saw a toilet
until I was nine years old.
We had a hole outside.
Excuse me, there
was nothing there.
And through the-- sometimes I
get choked up, so pardon me.
So through the eyes of my
mother, because my father,
like many families, dumped us
when I was about six or seven.
A shameful, shameful
reflection on men.
All over the world, by the way.
It's not unique to America.
So at a very young age, all
of a sudden there we were.
My mother had to
fend for herself.
And I had no brothers and
sisters, I'm an only child.
Which explains why
I talk so much.
And there was a realization,
stark or otherwise,
that I couldn't depend,
even on my parents,
to get food in my mouth,
and to live and stuff.
I, at a very young age, although
I couldn't verbalize it,
I knew I had to depend on me.
First lesson in life.
First cure, first step of
curing the entitlement age
that we live in, which is
that the masses are still
connected at the teat to the
United States government.
I'm not working this week.
They'll pay me a weekly
salary until I can't work.
I need help with
my job, job things.
I need food stamps,
you need food.
So the government
will take care of it.
And I don't ascribe
or prescribe to that.
I don't remember what
the question was,
but I wanted to answer it.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: It was about you
having an inspirational book--
GENE SIMMONS: My
mother continues
to be the greatest inspiration.
Which is, if you take
away all your stuff,
could you do it again,
in a different field?
See?
So I'm in a band.
And I have a restaurant chain
called Rock and Brews, which
is at Los Angeles, and
Nashville, and Kansas
City, Maui, Cabo.
Everywhere.
It's exploding.
And I own a football team.
The only one in Los
Angeles called LA KISS.
We're on CBS Sports,
ESPN, and all that stuff.
Branding, licensing,
merchandising.
KISS is celebrating
our 40th anniversary.
And boy, do I look good.
We continue to tour the world.
I leave Friday from New
York, and go to Mexico City
where we're going to be
playing the stadium there.
The day after, I go
to Phoenix to continue
with Me, Inc.
promotion and stuff.
Then hop on to the Bahamas
for the KISS cruise,
where 4,000 or 5,000
crazy KISS fans
pay about five grand apiece.
Let me see, that's $20
to $25 million gross.
We take 70%.
And then I go into a Vegas
residency-- in other words,
the band would be
enough for anybody.
But I'm voracious.
That's a big word
like gymnasium.
I want to read everything.
I want to learn
stuff I don't know,
because the mouse
when it first starts
to learn how the
maze works, is alive.
Because you don't know
where you're going,
and it's the hunt, you
know, not the kill.
And that's a killer
mouse that's going in,
finally gets to the cheese.
Now unless, and if, that
maze continues to change,
that mouse is going
to take its time
and get fat, bloated, and lazy,
and finally get to the cheese.
Because it knows
where it's going.
Give me a new maze every day.
I want to lose my killer
instinct, you know?
So every day, as
far as I'm concerned
should be a new Me, Inc.
New Me incorporated.
Because I am the business.
I am.
I have an inferred
fiduciary duty to myself.
I have to balance my budget.
Yes, I know there are corporate
entities, and conduits,
and other stuff.
But how much I spend should be
much less than how much I make.
Because remember, the
IRS is your partner.
They're right in bed,
right beside you.
And at the highest
tax rate, which
is not far from--
of course, you're
already making over
$250,000 a year.
But they're going to take 50%
of your gross pretax dollars.
And there's insurance, and
houses, and [INAUDIBLE].
And you're paying
with after tax money.
So it costs a
fortune to survive.
Never mind having kids.
Raising one child,
at the lowest rate,
is about $500,000 pre-tax.
Which means by the
time they're 18,
you will have had to
earn a million dollars
to raise one child.
Multiply that by 10.
The numbers are staggering.
You have to take
charge of your life.
I do a better job at running
me, Gene Simmons Incorporated,
than the United
States government does
of taking care of America.
We're almost $17, maybe
even $18 trillion in debt.
I've never been in debt.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: Speaking
of big business,
you went to school in
south Williamsburg.
Have you been back recently?
GENE SIMMONS: Oh, I did
worse than school there.
I went to Yeshiva.
I was a Hasidic Jew.
You know, Hasidim, but
I don't believe them?
Yeah.
I know I don't look
like I come from Sweden,
but when I first
came to America,
my mother wisely wanted to
keep me off the streets.
Because in Williamsburg, it
was the Williamsburg Dragons.
And it was a street
gang made up of guys,
and I never heard of Christ
or anything like that.
And I started, in broken
English and stuff,
at night if I stayed out
there longer than 10:00 PM,
I'd hear "Christ killer."
Never heard of
Christ, didn't know
what they were talking about.
But they were
coming after me, you
know, trying to do
some harm, just because
of my religious beliefs.
And I was a Jew.
It wasn't popular then, it's
still not a popular thing.
But by the way, it's
not popular to be
a woman, everybody picks on you.
It's not popular to
be black, Hispanic.
We all have our crosses to bear.
So fucking what?
Get over it.
Cry over there, there's
a puddle of water,
everybody takes their turn.
They say I was a kid and
everybody picked on me.
But you're right the
world is an unfair place.
It's prejudiced.
It's biased.
He will think-- I'm a Jew.
He's gay.
Fuck all of you, OK?
Get over it.
Now of course it's tough when
you're black, gay, Jewish,
like a lot of stuff.
Like then, you've
got a lot of stuff.
And you can get over that too.
Everybody's got their stuff.
At least America
gives you a shot.
In this biased,
racist world, we have
an African American president.
So you can do anything.
We may even have a female
president next time.
So cry to your mommy.
I don't really give a shit.
Just get out there.
You know the military's got
a great phrase-- shame on you
if you don't get up, and
be all that you can be.
Could you imagine if you don't
live up to your potential?
And I guarantee you that
there's greater greatness in you
than you ever imagined.
Because once upon a time,
when you were little child,
did you ever, I'm making it
up, you're making $100 grand
a year.
Did you ever envision
more than that?
AUDIENCE:Oh yeah.
GENE SIMMONS: OK.
$100 million a day.
I don't know.
When you were a kid,
you couldn't imagine.
If I found $1 on the floor--
so perception of wealth,
and how you're doing in life
is all based on where you are,
and what you can perceive.
And I'm telling
you that the future
can be so much bigger, and
so much greater for you.
And more is a good word.
And aspirational is a good word.
And self empowerment
is a good word.
And no it's never enough, bitch.
No, it's never.
I just want enough to get by.
You're a liar.
You're lying to you,
and you're lying to me.
And I'll prove it you.
OK, I've got to stand up
for a dramatic moment.
Because I also want you
to look at me, not him.
OK.
So for all you
hippies out there.
Oh, you're all
about money, you--
That's right.
I am all about money.
Even God passes the hat.
So just stay with me for second.
I just want enough
money to get by in life.
That's a lie.
By the way, if you know anybody
who says that, make sure
they know where to get me,
because I want every dollar
you don't want.
Just send it to me.
So God miraculously appears to
everyone here, and to hippies,
and to communists,
and to fascists,
and every-- the rich, even
appears to Zuckerberg.
Though probably less.
So God appears to Zuckerberg,
all way down to the poorest
person, and says, I know
what's in your pocket.
I know how much
money you got there,
because after all I'm God.
So I'm going to
give you a choice.
One of the few times ever that
I'm going to give you choice.
You can have more money in
that pocket, or less money.
What would all sane
human beings say?
Rich and poor,
anywhere in the world.
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: More.
GENE SIMMONS: See?
I'm just like you.
I want more.
Trust me.
Zuckerberg, and Gates,
and Buffett, and everybody
gets up every day and goes to
work, because they want more.
They want to get richer and
more powerful and stuff.
Now the fact that
you can actually
do good with your money,
and give to charity the way
Buffett's given half and
Bill has given-- that's fine.
And even if you're a fucking
rich, capitalist pig,
and don't want to give a penny
to charity, the very fact
that you are rich, and build
mansions, and do whatever
you do, you're creating jobs.
That's how capitalism works.
You feed people, even though
you don't want to feed people.
You create jobs.
So that's it.
I like capitalism
SCOTT SOSEBEE: Is there a
point where you draw the line?
You don't really talk
about business ethics
much in the book.
GENE SIMMONS: Of course.
I'd like to think that there's
a vague definition of good guy.
But for instance, you
know, it's relative.
Here's what I mean.
It is against, the law to
buy or sell, as an example,
Cuban cigars.
It's against the law.
If you do, you're a criminal,
you pay fines, you go to jail.
But I don't consider
that a criminal.
Because if you were
living in Cuba,
and you bought and
sold Cuban cigars,
you're not hurting anybody.
In fact are contributing to the
commerce, you don't go to jail.
So there is a kind
of an ethical,
moral bad that I agree with.
And probably with yours.
Sort of the biblical version--
don't kill, don't steal.
And by the way, in
Hebrew, you guys
misrepresented what the
original Aramaic in Hebrew says.
It's not do not kill.
It says, do not murder.
Because if it said, do not
kill, along with, do not steal,
you couldn't have
cops and the military.
Of course you can kill.
You can kill all
the Nazis you want.
It's OK.
It says, do not murder.
So I believe in
ethical, but in a sort
of a victim, ethical
definition of it.
Because there are some gray
areas, where nobody gets
hurt, and everybody
wants to do it.
As an example, my limo driver
Christo, who's a Greek,
was telling me that
when he was a kid,
they used to steal
candies from [? thing ?],
and the cops took him
down in the basement,
and beat the crap out
of them in New Jersey.
Then his father came down,
beat the crap out of him again.
He said, that's the
last time I did that.
But, you know, we're street
kids, and we did stuff.
And we're going down the
street, my guys and I,
and we saw this guy come
out of a grocery store.
And you know, I
held up the thing,
and he had a gun, so we ran
after him, and took the gun.
And we beat the shit
out of that guy.
Because we brought the
groceries back to them.
And the cop car came
up, and he said to them,
what do you got, what
are you doing over here?
And Christo, whose
name should be Christos
because if it's real Greek,
said this guy stole the thing,
here's the gun-- And
the cop said, I'm
going to go around
the block a few times.
Let me know when you
catch the assailant.
Good for that cop.
Because the justice
system would-- Oh,
did somebody hurt you?
Did your father molest
you when you were a child?
Oh, here let me rehabilitate you
The justice system
is, hypothetically OK.
I also believe in
street justice.
Somebody commits a crime,
and you beat up somebody,
I know it's not perfect, there
will be some innocent victims.
Somebody beats up something,
before the cops get there?
Beat the shit out of that guy.
Because nothing will happen
to him in the system.
Don't get me started.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: So the book
is a really good roadmap
to getting rich.
I want to-- you're here to
talk about the book, right?
Do you think you're
inviting people
into the rich dudes club?
This is teaching
everyone how to be rich.
Do you think, like, Trump's
sitting, being like,
Gene, what are you doing?
Why are you telling
everybody how to do this?
GENE SIMMONS:No, no, no, no.
The rich guys aren't afraid
that more people come in.
Because the more
rich people come
into the rich class, the
more business you make.
Look, as an example, if
I was the only rich dude
around on earth, I
couldn't get richer.
Not really, I mean I'd do the
old futile English system,
where you'd give me pennies.
I don't like to do that.
I like the LIBOR.
London International
Banking Rates,
where people are lending each
other billions and billions,
and charging each other
hundreds of millions.
Yeah.
The more rich people there
are, the richer you can get.
And the more jobs you create.
The big secret is, there's
no limit to how many people
can join the rich club.
That's the big secret.
Really.
And something about America
prevents the culture
from looking at rich,
especially self-made rich,
as a good thing.
You're suspicious of it.
It's very strange to me.
Because that very
pretty young lady,
if she won the lottery
today, and won $100 million,
we would throw a
parade in her honor.
Whoopee, you won $199 million.
She didn't do a fucking
thing to earn that money.
But she gets an interview with
you, right here at Google.
You won $100 million, fantastic.
If I work for it every single
day of my life, and now I'm 65,
and by the time I'm 65,
I make $100 million--
I have a lot more than
that, then it's suspicious.
Well, what did you do
to get there and stuff?
I think that's wrong.
I think you should praise
by the sweat of thy brow.
If you make it, and
you worked for it,
that's the parade
you should-- not
the guy that won the lottery.
You didn't do anything
to deserve it.
You know, all the
races that people
have won in the
Olympics, nobody just
walks across the finish line.
You've got to train
the whole year,
and if you're the fastest
of the fastest, that's
the one that gets
the, yay, you win.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: In
the same respect,
you were talking about
handouts, governmental handouts.
What do you think about
funding for the arts?
Where you stand on that?
GENE SIMMONS: I'm
totally against it.
SCOTT SOSEBEE: OK, well
you had made a comment
in the press about how rock
had been murdered recently.
GENE SIMMONS: Oh, but
rock is dead a long time--
rock died a long time ago.
But I'm totally against
government handouts ,
and I'll tell you why.
Because it takes the
power away from you.
The power of the wallet.
Look, WNET here in New
York, all the stations
that nobody watches.
You know the ones.
There's ballet on,
a guy is long winded
about a historical event
that happens, something.
And you go right to whatever
the latest, Big Bang
Theory or something.
That's the thing that
gets billions, millions.
No, I'm against government
handouts for almost anything.
Really.
I like incentives.
You know, I support
1,400 kids in Africa,
and I have for 25 years.
Clothe them, and then feed
them, and all that stuff.
But you've got to
come to school.
If you come to school, you
can eat as much as you want,
one meal a day.
Stuff your Bellies.
Here's clothing.
If you don't come to
school, you don't eat.
You have to have the incentive.
I ascribe and prescribe
to the micro banks,
especially in Africa, where
you loan somebody money.
Usually a single mother,
because the fathers,
there you go again,
run out on them.
So you've got single mothers
in Africa, here's $1,000.
They give the single
mother in Zimbabwe $1,000.
She can then buy cows and
sheep, and changes the economy
of the system, can
support herself.
Then she pays back
to that amount
to the micro bank, no interest,
and the micro bank loans
that amount again to
another deserving mother.
I like that idea.
Don't give them fish.
Teach them how to fish, so
that you have a sense of pride.
Charity is easy.
Here's $1,000.
No, no.
Get the graffiti off this
building, I'll give you $1,000.
Clean up the streets.
You made a job.
You don't have to
say thank you to me.
It's a job.
Create jobs, under
the guise of charity.
And kick unions in the nuts
and make them stand over there
and be quiet.
Because as far as I'm concerned,
it is the wonderful idea,
an ideal when we had child
labor, and the rich fat cats
really were bad guys.
Sort of Robin Hood economics, I
used on Varney & Company today.
I'm totally against them.
Here's why.
Once upon a time, the
Sheriff of Nottingham,
and the feudal lords of
England really were bad guys.
Everybody were slaves,
the literate, and so on,
and it was a feudal society.
And there was no
upward mobility.
They were a illiterate,
and everything else,
and only the rich, the few
rich, controlled everything.
And so Robin Hood stole from
the rich, and gave to the poor.
Good for Robin Hood-- then.
Nowadays, the rich
are self made.
They create jobs.
They pay, something like,
over 50% of the taxes.
5% pay the vast majority
of all taxes in America.
The rich are good.
As far as I'm concerned,
the rich are the good guys.
I don't see Wall Street as evil.
I see them as the people
who loan you money,
so you can have cellphones,
the infrastructure in America.
Without them, you
would have chaos.
Yeah, there are bad people.
Yes, Bank of America stole
and Goldman Sachs stole.
Yeah, human beings steal.
OK.
But the basic sense of it
is, Robin Hood economics,
and I made that up today
on Varney & Company,
is a bad thing, I believe.
Because you're going to
punish the people who
create all the jobs.
Go ahead, give them a reason
to move to Switzerland,
and take their money and
put tens of thousands
of people-- one of those
rich, fat cats leaves,
he takes his business with
him, and you're, fucked.
Be nice to the rich.
Especially if they're self made.
They give you jobs.
It's not a popular thing.
Too bad.
I create jobs.
I'm rich.
I create lots of jobs,
because I like that.
It's a good thing.
I don't want my
money to stand still,
because inflation eats it up.
So I reinvested it.
I create new things, and
do all that kind of stuff.
That's good for everybody.
Yeah, it gets quiet, you
don't like that, huh?
You like the idyllic guy, that
comes in on a white horse,
and just throws
the money around.
Yeah, well that's
not going to fly.
I don't believe that.
I'm not a fan of that at all.
So "Me, Inc."
Is how you can be the
Superman and Superwoman that's
lurking inside of you,
waiting to get out.
SCOTT SOSEBEE:
Gene, thank you so
much for joining us here today.
It's been a pleasure.
Thanks to all of you for coming.